you've probably heard people talking
about bitcoin as digital gold one of the
things that most people don't understand
is that actually bitcoin and gold are
both sound money what do i mean well
gold is the physical asset that embodies
sound money principles bitcoin is the
digital asset now of course sound money
people hear that all the time they don't
know what it actually means there's two
simple criteria that make up sound money
it's outside the system meaning that it
is created outside of the traditional
financial system and also no one can
create more of it obviously with gold
nobody can create gold you got to go dig
it up out of the ground and with bitcoin
there will only ever be 21 million no
one can create more of it so gold is
physical sound money and bitcoin is
digital sound money now why is this
important well because people have been
talking about how gold hasn't performed
well over the last decade or so even
with the backdrop of trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars being
printed by governments around the world
and very high levels of inflation of
course bitcoin has stolen the spotlight
it is getting labeled as digital gold
and it's the talk of the town but now we
have hard data that actually shows that
sound money has had a great decade just
bitcoin is the winner we've got this
tweet here from charles edwards that
says here's what really happened to gold
it didn't go sideways for 10 years
hard money had a massive breakout it's
just that 85 of the capital flow goes to
bitcoin now if we zoom in on the chart
itself you can see that bitcoin
absolutely exploding over the last
decade or so whereas gold simply going
sideways now if we go and we look at
comparing these assets you can see that
bitcoin and gold if you go back to the
10 year mark bitcoin is up more than 1
million percent in the same time frame
gold only up 7
that's what i'm talking about when i say
outperformance now in the last 12 months
bitcoin's actually down 8 right now
because it's had a recent price drawdown
and had such a great 2021 gold up 3
percent goldbug should be celebrating
the 12 month performance but if you go
back anywhere more than that obviously
bitcoin has drastically outperformed
physical sound money but if we go and we
look at the market caps what we can see
is that gold is still massive that shiny
rock at 10 trillion dollars or so in
market cap bitcoin only around 800
billion or so that means that bitcoin
simply has a lot of room to grow just to
match gold's market cap and so if you
are looking forward if sound money
continues to be adopted by the world and
continues to have capital flow into the
asset class
my bet is that the digital sound money
is going to do much much better than the
physical sound money either way
investors are betting trillions of
dollars in the market on what's going to
happen you know where i stand let's see
what happens